marketing for the now the marketing for
the now
marketing for the now marketing for the
now 10 minutes
12 remarkable guests for two hours
answering a sing dealer important
question
[Music]
are you ready gary what do you think
hey everybody welcome to vaynerx
presents marketing for the now
i'm andrea sullivan cmo of vaynerx and
i'm here with gary vaynerchuk the
creator of v
friends among other things yes happy one
year anniversary of marketing for the
now gary
thank you andrea it's great to see you
uh love your
love your uh painting or image behind it
it's pretty cool
yeah yeah going on great to see you very
excited about today's
show obviously a subject matter that
i've been engulfed in all year
and uh especially last month and um
i'm really excited about it we have a
ridiculous lineup we do have a
ridiculous lineup i just want to share a
couple we did some anniversary math
and we've hosted 22 episodes we've had
we featured 213
speakers i don't know how we got that
odd number um and viewership has climbed
up to 80
000 people per episode and we've hit 144
countries so thanks to everybody for
supporting us
hashtag marketing for the now let's go
because
friends we've got mark cuban he's the
owner of the dallas mavericks
let's go mavs and shark tank investor
welcome mark what's up guys thanks for
having me on
mark it's great to see you brother hey
bud how are you
i'm really well thanks for being on i'm
gonna go right into the first thing i
want to say which is
i think you are underrated
because i think you and i share
something and it and the final final
nail
in the coffin happened with this last
five six months with nfts as uh you know
i think you are incredibly
consumer-centric
and i don't think people talk about it
enough when i say that to you
you know because i everything that i've
come across on nfts
it just scares almost shakes me it makes
me happy because i admire you a lot
um i'm like man that's the same [ __ ]
that works for me
you don't come from a place of what's in
it for me
you come from a place of what's in it
for them and then you reverse engineer
that's what i believe i do
and i've noticed that through the years
you know obviously we know each other a
little bit but like
this one especially i feel like you and
i and maybe a couple other people have
been pretty aggressive
on it in a way that just feels exactly
like web 1.0 did for me
exactly what web 2.0 felt for me
and it probably shouldn't be a surprise
because of how much you nailed web one
and how intuitive you were in web 2 even
though you were so busy in what you were
doing
when i say that opening line does that
hit do you understand it and what how do
you take that
yeah of course i understand it i mean
you know the only benefit of technology
is when people benefit from it and you
have to understand
what the applications are and how people
can consume them
and so yeah i agree with you whether it
was you know my
my first company doing local area
networks before pretty much anybody else
doing streaming doing um the first all
high definition tv
um you know being vertical in 2006 with
owning a theater
and releasing movies on dvd and online
you know
it all comes down to what are people
going to consume what's the path the
least resistance for consumers
and if you can take the technology that
you're involved with
and supply that path of least resistance
and give them a better experience you're
going to win
mark i have a take that there's a lot of
1999
2000 internet dynamics playing out here
that
the macro nft thing is way way way
bigger than people actually realize
because it's gonna be
it's a social truth it's the
digitalization of assets we use those
assets to communicate
this is going to play out comma like 99
and 2000
there's so much excitement in a certain
group still a small group but excitement
that just like a lot of the internet
stocks were overpriced on the macro
long-term promise of internet
that a lot of the investing in the
individual
nfts have a lot of vulnerability as
supply and demand dynamics play out over
the next
half decade to maybe not be great
individual investments but the macro and
if you can find the amazon
and the ebay and the google in there
what do you think about that
i think i think you're wrong i don't
think it's 1999 and i think it's 1995.
right and i think it's not so much about
nfts nfts are proof of concept just like
you know in 1995
everybody was just setting up a website
and that website was
a business you know hey and it seemed
complicated to do html or javascript
right
yes oh i know somebody who does html
they must be really really smart
and and so every website seemed like a
business and everybody got excited about
it
but it turned out that was really just
proof of concept and the underlying
concept now
are smart contracts on evm's um ethereum
virtual machines
typically on ethereum but also on matic
in other places right
and you're starting it just like we
argued about
in streaming we argued real networks
versus um
net show versus all these other
streaming protocols right
now we're arguing about blockchains but
the reality is
smart contracts on ethereum and other
compatible blockchains
it's just the beginning and the proof of
concept is
nfts because anything digital
can be an nft and we've just scratched
the surface
on what truly is going to be done with
these smart contracts
who do you think the big winners are and
who are the big losers
in let's say the way you see the chess
moves playing out over next
let's i'm gonna i'm gonna truncate this
in the next five years
seven maybe i'll let you push it to ten
i'll let you go where you wanna go
who do you think really wins from this
at scale
consumers are now accustomed to a
non-custodial wallet they
you know i keep telling people my
friends i'm like don't be your
mom and dad they were scared to put a
credit card into a computer and now
you're scared
literally every person in my dad's
liquor store when i was like buy wine
library.com don't drive from new york to
the store
they were like i why my credit card's
gonna get stolen
right and that's what you saw in media
too right you know that's what tv was
really big
you know and i remember doing streaming
and people like i don't know what
internet broadcasting is but i'll just
turn on my [ __ ] tv
correct leave me alone who do you think
who do you think mark's going to do
the question yeah who do you think who
do you think's positioned to really do
nicely
and who do you think loses a little bit
of leverage in a
scaled internet and now an emergingly
scaled blockchain ecosystem
too early to tell it really really is i
think ethereum will be fine
and the reason i say that is because
it's what
it's it's the platform everybody's
trying to compete with
and when you try to compete on speed
transactions per second
and pricing it's really really tough
because
everybody sets the same you know
milestones and benchmarks
and it's not like the people in the
ethereum community with their
eips or ethereum improvement proposals
aren't going to keep on moving forward
they they do and so the whole industry
is going to move forward smart contracts
will move forward
i think what's going to drive everything
is the applications so we're seeing you
know like what you've done
you've extended um the value proposition
for
nfts not just you know a digital picture
or movie
or whatever it may be you know you
you've extended the value and that was
ballsy because
i i wouldn't even want to be your
accountant or your tax guy
for the way you guys did it well
especially when you sell ethereum
at an ordinary income and it decides to
go in half i've had a very
intriguing 48 hours no questions just
like because you included
access to different events you know how
do you account for that
you know there's issues there so you
know that's one issue i mean things like
um cliff notes right why aren't clip
notes nfts you take your class you sell
them right someone's from
a publishing company and do all that we
still haven't solved music there's still
issues with royalties and extending them
across platforms right
so there's all these things that are
going to be solved at some point
and you know just like you use the
credit card analogy i use the streaming
analogy when we first started streaming
in 1995 in order to listen to
you know a radio station you had to have
a pc with a modem
with a i dial up isp with a tcp ip
client with a
a client to do the streaming with a you
know a batch file on a website
and now when you think about streaming
you just think about watching tv
watching the show you don't even know
what happens
before i lose before i lose you in a
minute is there
any logical reason for anyone to issue a
ticket to an event to concert a sporting
event some other
as we go and let's say the prices come
down because i can respect where
ethereum is right now with gas prices
but you could do it on wax you could do
it on others
and we'll see level two with ethereum is
there gonna be a tipping point we're in
a little bit here two years three years
one year five years where
there'll almost be no reason to not make
every ticket in nft because it becomes
a marketing collateral asset for that
issuer and
god forbid luca drops a hundred points
in a game in four years
it becomes a secondary derivative
royalty asset for your team
yeah and also it's you know it's
something
it's it's an enabler too so you can do
so many different things with it
but the question isn't will it it's when
and
the question becomes at what we'll start
doing it this coming season
where we'll issue an nft after you've
chosen your ticket on ticketmaster or
whatever right so gary has seat a3 and
section 109.
now we already know that we use the api
bam we'll give der
gary his nft and that comes with all the
associated value that we create for it
because there's no limit to the value we
can add to it
and then the hard part then is saying
okay how do we move that closer to the
origination of the purchase of the
ticket that'll take some time
yeah that'll take some time brother i
wish you well bro
congrats always a pleasure next up we've
got sarah zucker of the sarah hole
sarah is an artist and writer who
creates interdimensional tv
transmissions
with humor psychedelia mysticism and the
interplay of cutting edge and obsolete
technologies she's been conditioning her
work and
he's in the crypto arts base since early
2019
sarah's gift art has made over 6.6
billion times on giphy and she's the
jeopardy pumpkin
welcome sarah hi andrea i think you
might have a tab open
andrea there's an echo of some sorts
not sure take a look or maybe that's
coming actually are you on a phone
no yeah okay we'll figure it out no
worries maybe go on mute
andrea i'm not sure if there's something
going on there because you hear the echo
uh i do not okay no worries um
how are you i am great how are you i'm
incredibly well
uh why don't you start with a manifesto
what is your
i think that's what i'll probably start
doing for the rest of the show give me
your
two three minutes on what the many who
are watching here
need to know about nfts from your
incredible perspective as an og
and somebody who's been living with it
sure uh you know i get asked this a lot
and they really are as simple as
a container right nfts are a container
technology
uh i'm an artist who has a background in
the photographic fine art market so i
really see nfts as a complete
one-to-one analog from you know the way
a photographer could addition a
print of their work we as screen based
artists can now
edition our work in its native format
um it's really as simple and as
revolutionary as that
you know as someone who's worked with
video for for about a decade at this
point
it was always a difficult proposition to
try
and um monetize and find support for
your work you know you had to do all
these sort of
byzantine things to try and get yourself
supported as a video artist or as a gif
artist or a 3d artist um so it's it's
really interesting it's one of those
technologies that
in its simplicity it has as we've seen
broken this dam of support open for an
entire
uh subsection of artists who have really
been defining
our visual culture in metaverse online
for a long time at this point
i think that's exactly right um
team on the marketing for the outside
i've got nothing open and i don't know
why i'm echoing so
let's let's see if we can figure it out
if just text me if you have a oh there
we go i think somebody picked something
sarah um what is the response
from the artist community that's like
just wakes up right now and says my
god wait a minute has my life completely
changed do i actually
now have a practical means to instead of
using this
on the internet to get exposure which
might lead to something no the actual
thing becomes the thing
and could really change my life what
have been the whispers in your community
yeah you know it has been um
there's been a lot there's been a lot of
noise in the in the artist community
certainly because
um you know like with anything like this
you see
a lot of people sort of quickly grok
what it is and run with it
and um and there's also been a lot of
fear i think that has come up which
to me says a lot about the artist's
place in society really
you know i think a lot of us have for a
long time been very conditioned to
create our work
for free to seek visibility for our work
uh you know through social media and
proto-social media
like tumblr and it was always this model
of create good work
and then wait for emails you know you
were expected to create your work
and then wait for people to contact you
and potentially commission you and
potentially give you gigs
and this is such a complete flip or
flipping if you will
of uh of how we support ourselves as
artists
and um i think for a lot of people
there's there's disbelief
around that because you know uh
lived life and live experience really
conditions you to expect things to be a
certain way
and um and i think it's that it appears
maybe to some people almost like it's
easy money
um and i would be the first to say
nothing about this has been easy
you know where people are confused sarah
is
some of the people that moved first who
deserve it
moved first and fast were able to get
different economics
what everyone's about to realize sarah
and i'm sure you know this
is that can you hear me i hear you i'm
going to try putting headphones in
um yeah no worries no worries
we're working around it um the
thing that i think people are going to
realize is
that the supply and demand now now that
the cat's out of the bag
you're just going to have so many more
people creating art ones that have held
it in in the past
and there's just a supply in their
scenario but i i don't believe that the
artists that i've watched especially in
18 19 and early 20
that might have had some incredible
moments especially in that early
establishment
i believe they deserve it for taking the
risk and seeing it and finding it
i think they earned it through strategy
and now what's going to happen it's like
social media
in 2006 789 some people established dane
cook
established his fame by using myspace he
did
he earned that with the right strategy
then
everyone figures out social media is
something and then it becomes a supply
and
every 20 year old is trying to become
tick tock and instagram famous
not everyone's destined to i
i don't think every artist that is good
is gonna smash it selling nfts in 2023
i'm just happy
so many more will than would have had
the technology not come across
our paths you agree you disagree oh
absolutely i think
you know what you're hitting on and
thank you for saying that you know i
think you're absolutely right that
artists have been conditioned
to do the best we can with an attention
economy
that's what you know every artist i
think working today
knows the email of i'm not going to pay
you but i'll give you exposure
real quick real quick real quick i
apologize for interrupting
i would argue everybody's been living in
that i mean i've been living off of that
build exposure and then i've worked my
face off in building companies that
might
be able to now not as much
now i have options to not have to do
that i i view entre
a lot of entrepreneurs a lot of other i
think artistry
goes pretty broad you have comedians who
are putting out clips that get 40
million views on a tick tock post
who are now potentially going to sell
these
that comedy it's really a fascinating
time no
oh completely we've added this extra
component
you know it's we're essentially just
adding to the attention economy this
component which allows us to then
uh convert that attention into financial
support
into something that says we are now no
longer expecting
expecting support to trickle down to us
sort of at the end of the line once the
platforms once everything else has taken
its cut it's now allowing us to really
take the reins
on what we're doing here sarah do you
think you know one thing i've seen from
some of the artists community is like
gary
you know friends are like but it's not
fair this athlete's doing it and this is
doing it and they're taking away from us
and like brother
you've been talking about freedom of art
well this is freedom of art you can't
have it both ways
have you seen that conversation spin up
and have you kind of
what's your point of view on that you
know i have and i see
i see like i said there's a lot of noise
in the community it can be quite
deafening at times um and what i always
say about the space is that it's
self-electing right that it's
something that creating nfts and that's
what i mean by it's very hard for people
to
shake their sense of how things should
be
because of how things have always been
um and it's i don't know if you've ever
seen the meme of the kid
holding it's like he has a boot on his
head and then and then it zooms out and
you see he's holding the boot on his
head
that's kind of what it brings up for me
of like no one is getting in your way
except yourself in this regard that this
is something you elect yourself to do
and i will say this as someone who you
know i had a very modest
social media following prior to this i
of course was a was a
very dedicated artist for many years but
i was not coming to this space as
someone
who you would consider to be a celebrity
um and i have really
uh myself and many of the artists in
this space have established ourselves
by continuous good work that is as
simple as that continuous good work look
if the god the queen if she of
art came down and said okay i'm the
official voice
and sarah you're just as good as darrell
and donnie and susan over here
but you moved quicker and more strategic
so your
impact financially and awareness is
going to be different because darrell
and susie
and donnie are destined to come in in a
year and the supply and demand curves
are going to be different
that is how it's going to play out it is
it's what i remind artists because i do
you know i
am an artist first you know and i and i
want as best i can to help artists who
are naturally
sensitive people um you know
just just take care of their mental
health and all of this that i remind
them
that your sales have nothing to do with
the quality of your art really like
those two things are perhaps related but
they are
there's not causality or correlation
there um
that this is ultimately a market this is
something that is a market
if you're coming in late to a market and
the market is already very saturated
you are going to have a much harder time
establishing yourself
sarah very famous people have sold no
nfts you know this
yes some of the most famous people in
the world have launched nfts in the last
two months
sometimes in collaboration with a great
digital artist and have sold nothing
because they didn't build it or they
didn't market it
or they didn't launch it with the right
strategy right and i think you're
hitting on something really important
here which is
authenticity has a great deal of value
in in this space i think and my
experience has been that
crypto native people can smell [ __ ]
from a mile off
and humans can't right humans can
totally
um and and that's when i see that happen
i think
that it's it's that uh everything we're
doing here is a question around
what has value and why and why do we
give it value
and when it's perceived as someone
coming in with this energy of
sort of like they're just coming in from
left field because they smell money
people just go i don't want to give you
my money you know
at the end yeah yeah once and i know we
have to go
i'm ready andrea i know i'm having too
much fun with sarah and went over and i
don't usually do that
or sarah when the the the
artist whether it's someone famous or an
artist even maybe from
real physical art they come in with
audacity as if they are
owed or deserved which is ludicrous
it is it is ludicrous and i think that's
what excites people about this space
is a feeling of of course of course it's
like i said it's not
necessarily correlated to quality but
there is a sense
of um it's just it's just tumbling those
those feelings of entitlement and those
feelings of who is owed what
and i think that excites people that
we're seeing a different group of people
kind of come to the forefront
with this i love it thank you for being
on the show
my pleasure thank you for having me
next up we celebrate tom bilyeu tom has
quite a personal story in addition to
being a billion dollar entrepreneur he
co-founded juggernaut quest nutrition
and is now the ceo and co-founder of
impact theory
where his studio produces tons of
content including the company's flagship
series
impact theory with tom bilyeu where he
interviews the world's highest achievers
in order to unlock their secrets to
success and a powerful mindset
welcome tom thank you
tom great to see you what's up dude
great to see you brother
same man looking at yourself knowing you
personally
uh this did you do the same thing i did
in in december january i don't know when
you did it where you were just like
thank you god for
letting me be at this point in my life
when this thing came along
uh no doubt yeah i got introduced to the
idea of of digital rarity
about six years ago and the guy showed
it to me and i was like whoa whoa
that is going to entirely change my
business and then promptly forgot about
it because the tech wasn't ready yet
obviously
we didn't have the network effects but
so when it came back on my radar
i was like we are all in we are moving
millions of dollars allocated to
building things out
in the you know blockchain space
especially nfts
and have really stayed true to like this
is changing our entire business so
it's uh this is a thrill ride
what's uh what's your early observations
what do you think
so right now people need to look at this
as a technology and so i
am uh unlike you who were sort of savvy
enough when
web 1.0 came around you got that early
for me i was in filmmaker mode so that
was just a non-entity i wasn't thinking
about that at
all i was just how do i break into
hollywood it was a totally different
game
that passes me by i get into business
much later probably
what 2003 i finally embark on my
business journey
this is post collapse like you know so
i'm coming into this oh like technology
is a thing and
uh that was now looking back really sad
to have missed that so
seeing this now seeing the energy seeing
how
there's just this sucking sound of like
talent and excitement
pouring into this space and
you know wanting to be in it from the
ground up wanting to build something
long-term and that's my
the sort of key insight and is what's
allowing us to get a lot of artists on
our platform
at a time where you know everybody's got
a platform is we give them our best
practices document and say look
this is about long-term this is about
building a community and people can see
my track record i know how to build
communities that that's like what i do
so i'm like look we're going to help you
guys build a community
and help you build out a long-term
strategy don't think of this as like
that quick cash grab
and then the next part is this is a
technology and so as an artist
you've gotta now broaden your canvas of
possibilities
of how you give that like moment of awe
where you're giving people the chills
through your art because you understood
that the
you know the modern canvas now can
douche it and so it's it's a really
interesting moment
what uh there's a lot of entrepreneurs
in here
a lot of different people what it you
know we've only got
five minutes what what is like go bullet
point for me bullet point things that
people should do or think about
if they want to leverage blockchain and
nft yeah if they're watching this right
we've had three people on now with me
i've been yapping forever like the
energy's building they're like all right
you know maybe i believe i've got people
yeah maybe i believe it maybe i don't
i'm not cynical i'm actually gonna i'm
not gonna do what i did with the
internet and with social media and say
no no no
this time trick me once treat me twice
but this third time i'm not missing
how do you think about it yeah number
one is
people need to learn about the
technology so the entrepreneurs that are
gonna win
are the ones that can create something
other people can't create simply because
they know what i call the physics of the
situation
so there's a guy that i think is really
worth following his name is garyvee i
don't know if you've seen him
but he talks he talks a lot about this
idea of like waking up and looking
what's popping off in the app store
that's somebody who understands
attention understands human psychology
and goes okay based on what i know about
human psychology you know you tell that
famous story you put the sign
here right and so as people are getting
into nfts
if you don't understand the physics of
that technology
one second i apologize there's somebody
spamming on facebook
acting as me putting a wallet up let's
ban that person and also i will never
ask you for money i will never ask you
for your metaphrase
a metamask seed phrase you know sorry to
cut you off
tom but i'd love to get your perspective
when it's the wild wild west you also
get a lot of the scammers out there
yeah people have got to get educated and
this is where
taking full responsibility for yourself
and
educating yourself before you do
anything is the key now taking action
i think is the most important thing that
you can do so bullet point number two
so if number one was learn the
technology number two was now go
create something and when i told our
team
that um when i first told them years ago
hey we're gonna get into comics and we
were like a youtube channel they were
all very confused
and 10 months later we've got comic
books on stands and my own team was like
how did we just pull that off
right but it's just what are the physics
of the situation and so i went into
extreme learn mode so i did the same
thing with nfts all right cool the
technology's here but i don't know the
technology
so now i need to get under the hood take
every meeting i can start learning
solidity
look at you know flow blockchain what's
what are its advantages wax what are its
advantages ethereum what are its
advantages
where do i think people are going to be
right skate to where the puck is going
to be not where it is
there was no way for me to sort of think
my way through that i had to start
building
so i found a tech guy we originally
thought we were going to build on flow
then actually getting into sort of where
that tech was compared to what i
needed to do realized nope we need to be
over on
ethereum and so that wasn't something i
could think my way to and so getting
people super comfortable with go take
action go mint an nft go
put it out there create something get
feedback
that's going to be huge and then number
three this is a community game so
no matter what you're creating on an nft
if you're not building a community and
holding yourself accountable to what's
going to happen
over the next 10 years like what i put
out today will be scrutinized 10 years
from now and my community is
is it's going to be on the [ __ ]
blockchain so like there there is that
history which now can work for you
which is amazing you know i say a lot
that being in the era that we're in with
social media and now the blockchain
you're living in a phenomenal time
because being a good person
suddenly is the greatest marketing
vehicle of all time go figure
it's crazy but like that wasn't always
true or at least it wasn't
easy to get it out there correct because
it was because there was too many
gatekeepers
the inner a mature internet and a mature
blockchain
is a very remarkable reality that
everybody watching this god willing good
health
will live through and it's gonna be real
[ __ ] different tom
yeah man and people gotta cut through
the noise so especially right now we're
recording this in the middle like a day
after
a catastrophic dip in the market
and if people have that long-term vision
and they understand the technology you
can actually create a functional thesis
so the question i come back to as the
market is plummeting
is is digital adoption a one-way street
yes or no
if it's a two-way street and people
might um maybe i like this internet
thing but you know know what actually
i'm going to totally abandon the
internet or maybe i like this blockchain
thing no i'm going to totally abandon it
to me my thesis is it is a one-way
street it is
hope of a better future it brings new
abilities that we didn't have before
and i cannot see in any meaningful way
that people will ever backtrack
so now it's like sure there's going to
be sort of winners and losers of the
specifics
but if you're betting on the technology
the blockchain
if you're betting on um you know
decentralizing you're going to win
i agree tom great to see you brother
brother thanks for having me on
next we welcome q harrison terry an
entrepreneur who founded 23v
the world's first digital art
marketplace powered by the blockchain he
recently sold the world star hip-hop
chain
for 121 eth on open c and is also the
author of the nft handbook which is
being published by wiley later on this
year
every year q harrison picks one skill
that he knows very little about
and challenges himself to master it this
year
japanese welcome q harrison
what's up y'all what's up uh garyvee
what's poppin
i mean it's great to see you life is
good for me what about you
yeah things are well thank you for
asking talk to me about
talk to me about your i'll be giving
everybody the first three minutes just a
uh manifesto 101 or 567 bullets that you
want the people
you know it's you you've been in it
you're doing your thing
what do people need to know or what
what's intriguing to you
it's still day zero right i think that
that's the first thing that
anyone that's looking at this whether
you got involved with it nine months ago
three years ago or you're just starting
today it's day zero for nfts and what
that means is
you can still learn and be impactful no
matter where you're at and because
there's so many industries that haven't
been nft
um yet or haven't picked up the
technology and decided to
use nfts in whatever fashion they will
uh you can possibly become that expert
and i think that like you know if they
to answer your question gary
what what would i recommend someone to
do is i would say go learn
right and i think learning is different
for everybody there's no
one-size-fits-all solution for
knowledge just in general right some
people learn better off instagram
other people learn better off a textbook
figure out what's most applicable for
you and go find the medium at which
uh there is nft inspiration there if
you're an instagram person you like
social media
at nft is a great place it's on
instagram you follow the account
every day there's new information
they're covering the highlights
and they're doing the research for you
so you can kind of see what's going on
and if you like something
go dig deep i think applying that
knowledge is the second point right if
you're gonna apply
uh your learnings that's the only way
you're going to understand and build
the comprehension that you need to even
teach others or you know
say this will or this won't work and
ultimately this nft space and gary i'm
curious your thoughts here
uh my third point would be about
showcasing you have to like this is one
of the few mediums
where you have to show up and showcase
the work in a way that you know not only
uh activates your community but also
gets the people talking right like all
of the nfc artists that you have on the
show today and just the people that have
done something they all have something
to show and that's the common thread
uh when it comes to showcasing your work
uh there's
there's tons of places you can go not
only i'm sorry it threw up but not only
do i agree with you i actually think
it's the variable
i think that people think it's the
technology i
i think the variable or even the art i
absolutely believe the variable is the
launch strategy
yeah yeah 100 and the expertise on the
launch strategy you can't go create a
wallet yesterday and say oh i'm
launching an nft and expect the
community to be with you
correct and and and you know for example
with v
friends i didn't want to go fiat i
wanted to educate
people on web 3 non-custodial
because i know i'm good at it i know i
have trust
i knew i could protect it i went
authentic with discord i went
authentic on chain minting right but it
took me 100 days
instead of just putting something out
you know what's funny is i was trying to
get some v
friends on the nfc side and every time
you do the drop i would miss it and then
i was just catching
the ones i wanted that people were
already selling them
yeah there we go and i was like damn
gary like i can't even get in
because you'll just put it out on
twitter and i'll see and i'm like god
i'm not the first person to see it
when did it when did you have your
eureka moment what's your eureka moments
so you're gonna love these uh i was a
digital art dealer in 2014 that's when i
first started dealing digital art um
at the time the i wasn't using the
blockchain i literally had like a couple
social media accounts i was
running around with the moniker rt
promoter i bought the domain on the
internet
uh put up a few you know social media
accounts and i was just going to artists
and i was like look
artists they make great work people have
money and they like to spend it on it
i'm broke i'm in college i could go work
at the library
i could go work at like some student
thing and like make like 15
an hour or i could go sell a piece of
art and figure it out and i could make
five ten thousand dollars
and so i was hitting people up in san
francisco new york peter vu was one of
our first like big big clients
and he's this new york artist so you
know i'm seeing it and i'm like wow in
the new york art world i'm in wisconsin
and i get a get a voo piece and of
course he's like you know some black kid
out of wisconsin trying to sell his
artwork and he's
this prestigious artist he's like oh
hell no but i'm like yo yo i'm like
i'm not trying to sell your actual work
i don't even want to sell the prints i
want to sell the digital variants and
he's like huh
and that's like no he was like no risk
to that i don't even know what the [ __ ]
that is
exactly and so like you know i thought
it was like yo you can scout you all of
your work starts
intrinsically uh on a digital medium i
was like if you're using adobe suite
those are all binary bits and pixels
if you're uh sketching on your galaxy
note because he was one of the he did a
samsung galaxy note campaign way
way back when right and so he he i mean
he used the no like he was actually one
of those people that was about it and a
lot of his sketches he started on his
note i'm like bro just give me those
files
and i'll sell them and so i ended up
long story short we started this
marketplace called 23 vivi long time ago
raised some money for it it was it was
fun we had you know a good time exit
i'll say we were way too early and we
were on the bitcoin blockchain
much different than what you see with
the ethereum blockchain and some of the
derivatives there
because you know bitcoin blockchain was
mad slow like
and and then at the time like i'm in
college so we're selling art
the way i did it was i told all my
friends i'd be like yo
just buy this art piece from me i'm
gonna sell it to you for a dollar cause
we did this reverse
uh ducks option model where i'd sell art
for a dollar just knowing that like it
was easier to sell something for a
dollar and it's just about momentum
like you just built that momentum you
get the sales and then you know things
kind of compound from there
so i would sell like the first 20 i
would only make 23 editions and
sometimes
we didn't make 23 editions sometimes we
only had 16 or 5 or 10 just to build
artificial scarcity
but the first editions always sold for
nominal prices they'd be like like ten
dollars five dollars twenty dollars
right
and i would then go create markets i'll
go i would know like four or five real
art collectors and i'd be like yo
you can get a peter voo piece for like
300 bucks and they're like really
i'm like yeah and then they would buy
for 300 right
i would tell my friends you're like
honestly bro
the only thing i'm thinking about right
now is like damn i wish q and i went to
college together
because we would have been on that
24-hour hustle
like you just you know you're grinding
and learning your way
yeah and so i did that i paid uh i paid
for a lot of college using
different hustles bitcoin i don't have a
lot of it today because
i mean that paid a lot of my tuition
yeah but uh
i mean i still stayed active in the
community so when nfts popped off again
uh like late last like september of last
year i still seeing it bubbling and i
was like
and you know i'm getting all these texts
and tweets and people like you are so
ahead of the curve blah blah blah
i'm like i'm like all right all right so
obviously you know i get the call one
day
um and they're like yo can you sell an
nft and i was like what
what do you mean like selling nft like
i'm that's that's not that's easy
and so uh i i wanted to apply the same
things i just talked about i wanted to
like say okay what do i know what
something about
and for the first time ever now the
general mass market is involved in you
know these digital wallets and
nfts and they want they want in and so i
i talked to the people over at worldstar
hip-hop
and i was like yo uh can i sell the
world star hip-hop chain and i know my
name's q i'm not the i'm not not trying
to impersonate q
uh from world star this is q harrison
but i want to sell the world star hip
hop chain
and they're like bro what are you
talking about you know world star you
know how it is right they're like
they're crowding up the room but they're
like at the same time like yo like what
is the kids
talking about and so i finally got them
to to get on board with it and you know
we uh
we reached out to the good people over
at lemonade tv to build the audience
visually
uh we did this auction style drop very
similar to 23 vivi but in this case we
like set the pricing set like yo it's a
digital chain there's only one of one
we're about to move a digital chain on
the blockchain like come catch it off
the block
and ben balder tweeted about it and then
he hopped on clubhouse and started
ranting
and obviously you have the first person
ever make the real world star chain
uh that caused all types of waves we hit
tmz and
you know block boy crypto talked about
it we saw the whole thing you saw yeah
yeah so then
yeah and then it it sold for 121 east
which is uh
i don't know today's price is probably
around three 300 000 somewhere around
there
but uh though that's the type of
thing those are the type of communities
that you really want to take nfts to
right like
in like the the world is effortless i
was talking to a company
uh they make uh they're in your realm
they're like a
alcoholic beverage company and they're
they're thinking about taking their
bottles and turning them into nfts and i
thought
that was a super cool concept and you
know you said something very very smart
right off the gate everything's gonna
get
[Music]
yeah it's inevitable that's right
i remember i said that about websites
people laughed i remember i said it
about social media accounts because i
pointed to like 45
50 year olds at the time like you're
gonna have a social media account they
laughed
everything's gonna nft everything the
nft
occasion of everything so so gary you're
gonna nfc this this moment right here
actually i can do it if you let me i get
your permission approved go cube
all right cool we're gonna turn this
into an nfc we'll drop it see you my man
thank you for being thanks man
one let's go next we welcome allison
weisbrot
editor of campaign allison is an
award-winning journalist with expertise
in advertising
marketing and technology today allison
may flip the script and
interview gary about what nfts mean for
the advertising industry
let's see all right yes we're going to
put me and
put gary in the hot seat now i didn't
even know this i'm excited allison how
are you
i'm good how are you real quick i just
two seconds
i just noticed somebody posted on
facebook garyvee what's good it's trash
from mount ida my boy
trash from college is in facebook i
haven't talked to him in 20 years trash
what's up my man i miss you
hit me up gary at vaynermedia.com we
gotta chop all right allison go ahead
all right so there's so much hype around
nfts
obviously you're really bullish on them
what's the long-term business
opportunity for brands and marketers who
are really trying to get into the space
well i think one thing that a lot of
brands don't realize is that
nfts are actually marketing collateral
you know if if planter is a client of
ours puts out
extraordinarily smart mr peanut nft
and it finds its way to a hundred
thousand wallets
the world i live in allison that a lot
of people don't get
is that public wallets right public
wallets
um need to and are going to
exist meaning that
if you have a public wallet
it will be similar to your instagram
account
so i live in that world i live in a
world that somebody's going to come
along
win the public wallet game and i'm going
to go to wallet.com
allison and look at the tokens you have
in the same way that i would google you
or go to your instagram today
i am completely in belief of that so
essentially
brands will need to have a presence the
way they do on a social media platform
in the form of a public wallet
the reverse they need to put out nfts
that are so
interesting that lots of people buy them
or have them
and then when people go and look at
people if i go to drake's
public wallet and see a dope
you know mr peanut nft that's good brand
equity
got it so it's so i believe when brands
realize this truth
and then start making nfts that aren't
[ __ ] just like put it out there
but something that's thoughtful has a
smart contract underneath it brings
extra value
then it gets interesting okay um
how did a lot of your guests that were
just previously on we're talking about
the nft community and how that's so
important to sort of get involved with
different communities who are
you know into the nft world um
how can brands do that i think a lot of
times when brands show up it seems
really cheesy and inauthentic
how can they like what types of brands
can really like make a play in this
space
i mean every brand can make a play
the problem is brands and agencies are
cheesy
i mean vayner does cheesy work it drives
me crazy
like like i don't need to point fingers
let me point thumbs
vayner does cheesy work because
advertising people do advertising [ __ ]
allison
so how can they not how can they take
advantage of this i stop being [ __ ]
cheesy
and i think it starts with the client
right i think you know
my my teams get into subconscious what
they think the client will say yes to
versus presenting the best work and
that's what i keep pushing them on right
so i do think it starts with the clients
being less scared yeah well that that
can be difficult i think
um so before we move on that's fear
is the devastator of life
you know people don't post things on
social media because they're scared
someone's gonna say they're ugly
brands don't do something smart because
they're scared it may go
wrong and then campaign's gonna write an
article that's
you know like like it's true that's what
they do and and i actually keep
reminding people that if you have good
intent
that it can only be so bad
right and i think people and they and by
the way
we also live in a world where everyone's
a keyboard warrior
people crapping on a brand on twitter
and then 24 hours
eating their sandwich even though they
don't you know like
from a business standpoint people love
to talk on the internet but don't
actually live their life that way
right right sticks and stones a little
bit
a little bit so a lot of the nft
conversation is around artwork
um buying and selling digital artwork
for businesses
is there any other viable use case
in creating nfts um yeah i mean i think
there are utilities i don't think a
single business will ever have
in f seven years i don't think a
business is going to have a
membership card why put it out as an nft
i think i think restaurants can launch
the restaurant selling nft
tables where that person owns that table
and it becomes like a rayos
situation i think there's a ton of
things coming
you know uh have you seen any good
examples yet
no you know it's it's extremely early
like
i i haven't stumbled on it i'm sure
there are
but like i think that every restaurant
should have an nft project where the nft
is
a discount code if you own it free food
if you own it
i have a lot of ideas in the restaurant
space specifically
interesting um so nft values you were
just talking about
have declined pretty rapidly but you're
still really bullish on it you think
anything everything will be
the nftification of everything i believe
was the phrase used
um you know how do you how do you see
the volatility in the space
um and also just sort of like the
newness of it
it's you know i've been through this
before right like i was there when
facebook stock
opened at 42 and went to 19. i was there
when everybody wrote
the internet off as dead in 2000. you
know
um so i think you know for me i'm
comfortable in this place i keep
reminding people don't be frivolous with
your money
don't do things that you can't afford to
lose
you know like this is um this is an
incredibly amazing time i do believe in
the
nft application of everything but i
think that's going to take a decade
and and do i think that somebody can buy
an nft today on openc
for a thousand bucks that's destined to
be 50 000 yes i do
do i think far more people are gonna buy
something for two thousand dollars that
are destined to be eighty-five dollars
i do i'll give you an example if you
bought
beanie babies at the height of ebay
beanie babies
then that didn't go to zero but the
princess diana beanie baby on ebay right
now is not what it was
in the height right at that same time
you could have bought a michael jordan
rookie card
for a lot less than it is today
alternative investments
have grown right you just have to pick
the right ones
yeah and you have to think long term i
think about it which is why you got to
think about
it and the person behind it
what do you mean by that well for
example one of the reasons i have a ton
of confidence with beef friends is
i'm good at building businesses and
brands and so
i'm going to build out these characters
and i think i have a legitimate chance
to make them
the smurfs or care bears or power
rangers because i'm
good at business and good at brand
building i if i was on the other side of
me would be more confident in my project
than somebody else who might have done
beautiful arts but has never built a
community or an economy
so how do you see the friends like what
have you learned so far from launching
it that other businesses can
can learn from as well and how do you
see it fitting into your overall
vayner empire um
i think i learned a lot of things one i
learned that we were very early the tech
was challenging we had to push it back a
week
i learned that um
i learned that what i always believe is
why my books have done well i'm a big
fan of selling early so building a
discord community for a month before it
came out really mattered
big shout out to everybody who's
watching from discord it's become an
incredible community
which has become a monster in itself
above and beyond when i'm in there the
community's
bigger and stronger than me um
education allison i wrote i put a lot of
time and effort into educating people
what a non-custodial wallet is you can't
buy my nft just with coinbase you have
to get a meta mask or a rainbow or a
wallet connect
education and community if you're going
to dive in today
are the two for sure yeah for sure
um so where do you see v friends going
i think it's going to be one of the most
significant intellectual properties born
out of native nft land in the history of
time
well i guess i should go buy one then i
can't give investment advice certain
things
but i can definitely tell you that i'm
incredibly i
i i can tell you this i've never ever
felt like this i feel like
i've always had this weird um point of
view on walt disney and vince mcmahon
and now i understand very clearly why i
was envious
i was like man it'd be so cool to create
a world
and the fact that i'm going to be able
to create a world around the things that
i am passionate about is gary vee
i'm also excited about taking a little
bit of a step back you know garyvee
is very much me living my life because i
know people
find the way i communicate interesting
and so it's a platform for me to talk
about
compassion and empathy and patience and
kindness
and hard work and ambition and
accountability things that my mom
instilled in me like things i really
genuinely alice and believe in
but i'm a loud aggressive compassionate
convicted
jersey boy and that means that a lot of
people aren't gonna
fall in love with me as a matter of fact
some people are like forget that guy the
fact that i'm gonna be able to use
empathy elephant
or patient panda or a countable aunt to
tell the stories that i believe in
that's a legacy that's interesting for
me that sounds awesome
i'm excited to see where it goes awesome
thanks for being on that was fun
uh andrea i like what you did there i i
think that is a format for she's
good she's really good she's amazing but
i've
never been on the other side i'm marking
for now also thank you never know on
marketing thank you allison
next up we've got mike winkelmann known
by many
as people mike is an artist living in
charleston south carolina
who has been at the forefront of digital
art for the last 20 years
he is best known for the everydays
project in which he has created a
picture from the start to finish for 14
plus years
this year christie's auction house
offered an nft
of a compilation of these images
entitled the first five thousand days
which sold
for 69.3 million dollars
welcome mike
i love both of us shaking our head with
that like when she said that both of us
are just like
oh my [ __ ] god mike you you put in
the work for a decade place you
taught yourself you got better at
drawing you you
figured out that karma and giving worked
your earliest breakthroughs were through
these you know
visual visual jockeying kind of video
jockeying for the music world
you know i see a lot of people have a p
you know anytime you're going to do
something like sell
a piece of digital art first and early
when the world knows nothing about nfts
for that kind of number
of course we have to have compassion for
society to have a ridiculous
overreaction in the other way saying who
is this guy that's bull makes sense
on the flip side for me i see a very
different story i see a man
who committed to his craft who did it
for
14 years who got better and better at
his craft who
had the natural storytelling talent and
then
recognized an innovation change that he
was able to apply against
and built momentum
i thought i think you forgot the luck
part there there's a little lock there's
a little luck
there listen you know people that work
hard
push against luck and and i get why
but of course luck you were lucky to be
born your mom and dad had sex at the
right moment
that was 400 trillion to one people
there you go i was born in the soviet
union
and what you know was born at a time
where they were going to let people out
i mean
luck is i'm lucky a tree didn't fall in
my head
it's true that's true okay enough about
my parents having sex let's get
i've got a bunch of questions too um
you're asking questions yes i have
questions too she copied me
respect go ahead okay so why did you do
the v friends on ethereum
it was you know ethereum's a platform i
invested in
in 2017-16 it was the place i was most
comfortable with
i believe in ethereum you know i myself
believe that in the platform long
term um uh the
the team at nft 42
that i decided to work with were
ethereum on chain
ogs so they felt most comfortable i
looked at wax
i didn't really look at flow mainly
because i was just cheering for like
they had their own
i was like flow's busy right they've got
nba top shot i love rohan but
i didn't really look i looked at wax a
little bit i just
felt i never you know i've said already
on here i only feel comfortable in doing
things i understand a little bit more
i was concerned about the gas fees i was
concerned about
you know you know the environmental
aspects i spent a lot of time on i
i spent time it's where i personally
felt most comfortable
are there any of the private blockchains
that you're like excited about it sounds
like
not super huge at the moment or the
usual actually
actually yesterday i had a team meeting
with my team phil aj others
and said all right guys now that i'm
kind of like over step one
my biggest passion is to really dig deep
and get my own opinions on polka dot
cosmos
you know um cardano solana like i want
to really learn
like i i don't view i i think it's
impossible
that in six years it's just ethereum
yeah so see that's the thing that i'm
kind of like going back and forth
on just because it's kind of like at
these prices especially i
i if if nfts are still around which i do
think they will be
like i feel like ethereum's going to be
the last one to go
like it's going to be like it's hard for
me to imagine a private blockchain
overtaking ethereum right i'm incredibly
i'm incredibly bullish on ethereum
but tomorrow sally might
announce something and i'm like a
hundred hours of work i'm gonna be like
oh my god
but no i think i think ethereum has
crossed into the and
category meaning it's gonna be ethereum
and whatever else happens
exactly that's right and that's why
that's where i feel
you know passionate and so looking at
them long term that's why it's very hard
yeah i get it people what um i have one
more question one more question
i'll ask one that you jump back okay as
a human you've had this incredibly
once in a lifetime moment you're you're
a couple of weeks months
you know a month or so plus away you
know removed from it
what's different because there has to be
something
it can't all be the same what's
different today than six months ago
and what's exactly the same because i
think it's for a lot of people here they
may win the lottery
they may have something tough happened
an adversity or something amazing happen
and i think hearing something this
jarring of a life change
might help somebody in what they're
going through right now which is why i
ask so what's different and what's the
same
um the same is that
i don't know i'm still like very focused
on making digital art super excited
about it and sort of like i didn't move
i didn't go buy a bunch of crazy crap
like it it sort of
in a lot of respects there's a lot that
didn't change um what did change is now
i have employees
and i'm doing kind of all the same
things to a degree
but on different sort of scale and sort
of a different
um yeah it's just like i'm doing most of
the things i was doing obviously i was
not making physical objects before nft
and that's a big
big difference from what i'm doing now
um
but it's it's kind of very similar to
what i was doing before
just on you know a much sort of like
broader scale and
and with a lot more sort of like
collaboration and people kind of like
helping me
but otherwise it's sort of like i don't
feel like it's sort of like
my life has taken a vastly different
direction
it just feels like accelerated and to be
quite honest i actually thought this
would happen
not to this level this quickly but i
actually thought that
when i hit 20 years of every days people
would pay way more attention than they
were
and so i i thought that i would have
some sort of like
national level attention when i hit 20
years that's what happened quicker than
i thought
good for you i was like sort of like i'm
not gonna stop doing this
people will catch up to you were you
more emotional when you saw your art in
the wild in
that trip that you took to hong kong or
more when
you got your first big sale in nft land
this year um
that is by the way i'm going to let you
ask your question now because that pause
alone
is what i was looking for and kind of
knew it would be true
yeah i don't know they were just
different it was kind of like it was
it was sort of like they're both just
different forms of kind of like
they're both different forms of like
external validation but at the same time
i really feel like
external validation is this [ __ ] it's
it's a
it's a it's a it's a uh
bittersweet it's one of these things
where it's good but it can also be like
yeah
don't get too [ __ ] focused on this
external validation i know when i do
something that's good
and i know when i do something that's
[ __ ] and it has nothing to do with
what other people think of it
and and and the more you're leaning on
other people
the more they can but my question is
good why'd you do the dutch auctions
i was worried that too many i've had
people over the last four years
want to invest in me mike in a way that
you can't imagine
really special wealthy credible
nice people i got very scared
that a lot of them and there's been a
lot of them would see
with this project for what it was which
was an incredible way
to invest in all my capabilities and i
was scared that they were going to price
out all of my community
and so i capped it
and it's worked out exactly the way i
wanted
when i go into my discord and i see
people in there
sitting with a v friend and i know
what's it
in the same [ __ ] way that you sat
there 13 years ago
maybe 12 years ago a year or two in and
saying one day
i [ __ ] know that the friends is gonna
be [ __ ] huge
disney [ __ ] [ __ ] scooby doo
[ __ ] harry potter hello kitty i will
not rest
until these characters mean a lot in
popular culture
and now now that my original
i feel like everybody in my community my
email my social
i've given them a chance now
with the twenty percent that are still
left on vfriends.com and i'm still
pissed you don't own a name we're gonna
fight
dude i know you don't know how to buy
nfts um
people but but now that i've given them
all a chance
now next week i'll go to
wealthy friends and really speak to them
one-on-one and say let me tell you what
i'm going to actually do these next 20
years and why
i'd like you to buy the end with the
price of ethereum right now
being you know i mean it's an incredible
opportu i'm just incredibly pumped how i
did it i left money on the table
yes but i have a royalty so i left money
on the table to make sure i took care of
my community
but now i'm gonna go to work like the
fact that i know somebody who had six
thousand dollars bought one for three
thousand
and one day is gonna sell it to somebody
i know that's super wealth like i'm
i can't tell you this robin hood like
game that i've been playing in my head
but i feel incredible today and the fact
that there's still about 20
of the inventory on the original website
and you can buy it excites the [ __ ] out
of me
because it feels like whoever really
believes in me is gonna benefit
and you probably feel this about your
original you must feel incredible
knowing that some people bought your
[ __ ] early on and now are making
incredible life-changing money for
themselves
because of the collateral impact that's
what i'm going to do at scale
no 100 i had a buddy bought one for a
thousand bucks and sold it for 200
000 bucks and like got all of his debt
and
one of the reasons i held back so many
tokens and then stamped them g-o-o
gary originally owned is because i'm
gonna give them to my sister and my
other friends
who are gonna it's gonna be
game-changing for them
anyway i love you pal dude thank you
dude talk to you soon
next we have mick nyem co-founder and
business officer of dapper labs the
creators of crypto kitties
flow and mba top shot mick is committed
to spreading blockchain education and
creating delightful ex
user experiences through partnerships
with the likes of ubisoft
samsung ufc dr seuss and of course the
nba
he joins us from lisbon where he was
kite surfing this morning
welcome man hey great to be here
good to see you gary nick great to see
you you know i've had the luxury more to
interact with rohan so i use
his name a lot when i give you guys daps
pun intended but
just thank you i think you know i think
when these books are truly written
it makes me happy that you and him and
others on the team
will get incredible accolades for the
advancements both with kiddies
both with nba top show these are
signature moments
in the short history of nft landscape
and so um
congratulations i mean that's really
darn neat i i personally
very much am passionate about
professional legacy it's fun it's what i
play for much more than money
and i think you've achieved that in the
way that at least i see the world
evolving so congrats on that
and also launching v
friends boy do i have a lot of
compassion for what you guys have from a
technical
challenge on these nba top shop drops
and so
it's good to have you here i'd love to
get an opening line from you on
as somebody who's really been here from
day ones
at least on the you know on the ethereum
with krypto and then building your own
like
what are you feeling like does this feel
like incredible external validation of
like [ __ ] i
[ __ ] knew this was gonna happen and
we're og's does it feel surreal
have you not even been able to focus on
that because you're in such hyper growth
and you've raised all this capital that
you're just focused on executing
what are your feelings i mean this kite
surfing is probably a requirement just
to balance out all the [ __ ] that's going
on right
uh the kitesurfing is meditation so
super important
um what are we feeling i think
it's it's just so cool to see a new
generation of creatives come into the
space
get it and be excited about it and and
so for me it's i'm just kind of
excited about what you're doing what
other people are doing and can try to
hear
appear outside my window and see like
what's what's cool that's coming next
because
i think it's going to be things that we
never imagined and for me
beyond just like making sure that we we
continue to do the things that we need
to do
to to make the nba top shock community
happy and to grow flow
i'm just really excited about what's
next and what
amazing people are going to do i think
what i love about nfts is that it's
unlike before where it was really just
financial people getting into blockchain
now we have this
new new types of people with completely
different ideas of what decentralization
means
and what it can do and so i just think
we're going to see a huge amount of
innovation over the next couple of years
talk to me about when you knew
pop shot was whoa
you know cause you know i got i got the
luxury through intro
from fred wilson to toto raham and
you're probably aware of this you know
and you guys and in july and i'm like oh
and i was just
so deep in like making sure vaynermedia
was gonna get through
covid but i remember thinking like oh
this is you know obviously because
and then i mean in my wildest dreams and
i'm usually good at this [ __ ]
i could have never thought zero to a hun
i mean i thought i had enough time to do
more stuff with you guys
and maybe like for 2023 right yeah i
mean you
you must have been super or maybe not
which is why i'm asking
it i mean it happened so [ __ ] fast
and so big
two questions am i right in the
assumption that it happened way bigger
way faster than you anticipated comma
because that's an easy
yes no when did you actually know
and like literally have that moment with
yourself and then communicate to your
co-founders
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] yes wow
i i i think there were like two moments
like one no we never expected this
like we thought it was gonna be a grind
and we were gonna grow
slowly but surely and and i still think
that it's it's still growing there's a
million people
who who um but the moment i
for me was when i saw a a a video tweet
of shaq saying
uh top shot this that's when i was like
oh okay
this thing this is really right it's
becoming a verb this is gonna happen
yeah
yeah like a tweet right yeah yeah no
exactly it's becoming a verb
and just like it's authentic like
players like this
and i think that was really important i
love that
but um when did somebody in your real
life
like a parent or a friend or a relative
realize you were that this had happened
one was
i love that story too i was curious well
i mean for me it was really
interesting when we did when created
crypto kitties i was trying to get all
my friends
to buy crypto kitties and
i i couldn't i like like they're looking
at me like they look at the cats and
then they're like well this is
complicated
um and i couldn't get it i've had for me
it was um
i i guess in february i had a bunch of i
have two friends who were telling me
i just trade top shot now like i'm at
work but i all i do is trade top shot
and that's when i was
when i realized like okay there's
something here
people that are my friends who don't
care about blockchain know
way more about the product that i'm that
i'm like contributing to building
than i do and that's what god really got
me really excited
what's um what's on your mind on the
macro space as somebody who has gone
from kitties to the nba top shot two of
the most substantial projects in the
history of nft land
what what do you besides your optimism
and excitement to see new stuff and
people innovate which makes sense
anything
nuanced that's exactly i i i think the
i think the important part is is is
really
kind of going back to it and thinking
like when you're creating a project is
what it's how is this going to be
valuable to your community to your users
rather than just saying
hey i can put pictures uh title 10 and
fd and sell them
and so i you did that with v friends i
was just on a call with a a
great designer who's got ideas around
smart con smart contracts that
help offset carbon um emissions it's
just really thinking about
i mean for us with nba top shot for us
it was like
how do we make a collectible that's ten
times better than a physical one and
that's
how we ended up with videos just
capturing those moments it's just
really like needing this for people to
have this focus of
if i'm putting something out there why
is it more valuable
for my audience and and how how am i
going to make
keep it valuable for that audience i
love it
what um for the 101s the day ones
in this final minute that i have you and
i appreciate your time
what's a good place to start how do you
answer that question
oh um i know they're looking at this
they're excited they feel it
you know they by the way let's talk
about you know
ethereum or top shot like these mark
early means volatile
yeah so like yeah i mean i i think like
i think the first place to start is
engage with a product engage with a
couple of products
play with them um as you mentioned
earlier don't go crazy and and spend all
your money on it but like
test it find find what you find
attractive with one
or another i i like playing around with
uh dnfts that are kind of game
related like f1 delta time and stuff
because i learned a lot around like what
it means to stake in nft et cetera and
so just
playing around with as many different
primitives just go deep in the
uh rabbit hole read but also play and
interact with taste it
taste it see what's wrong with it so
that you can come up with better ideas
i appreciate my man congratulations what
a run keep going
thanks next we welcome matt fort now
an entertainment lawyer turned tech
entrepreneur
matt co-founded commissioner.com the
web's first fanny
fantasy sports service which he sold to
cbs sports line for eight figures
as a copyright expert he co-authored the
bible of the music industry
this business of music and six years ago
matt dove into the world of
cryptocurrency and blockchain technology
creating the official nfts for iconic
brands such as
the three stooges welcome matt
yes thanks andrea gary nice to meet you
it's a real pleasure my friend
um why don't why don't i give you the
floor for your
to you know having a beer with a buddy
uh or a relative
and they're like what's this nft thing
riff for two or three minutes
yeah i get that a lot like what's in nft
i also get a lot like uh
nft is a scam uh i hear that a lot
i saw on the on the daily show recently
they did a whole thing about nfts being
a scam and i would just like to
say that nfts are the opposite of a scam
i agree
like the physical art world is a scam
with all the forgeries and the fakes
and the manufactured provenance
and even the even the collectible world
there's there's been a history of
forgeries and fakes and other types of
scams and doctoring of cards but with
with nfts it's the opposite of a scam
because with the blockchain technology
you can easily go on the blockchain on
etherscan and see
who the creator of the nft was the
entire the entire provenance chain of
title
from owner to owner and it's all
transparent so
for anyone who keeps saying who keeps
telling me nfts are a scam
it's the opposite of matt the reason
they say that
and we saw it with anything that gets
uber hot
expensive fast right internet companies
you were there
you know um let's talk about one that
played out
in a way that is an interesting one
beanie babies
right right you heard that and what was
true in that was
it because the people didn't if if if i
ran beanie babies matt
if beanie babies was mine right i
believe today that beanie babies
would be talked about the way that hello
kitty pokemon
and disney characters would because i
would have developed them
and had i would have and developed them
i believe beanie babies which oh by the
way
are selling on ebay right this second
for a lot more money than people think
just not the ludicrous price right
when i i know exactly why people are
saying it
on the flip side i couldn't agree with
you more
when people actually played by the way
the internet this was
all internet websites were a fad that's
all i heard
gary it's a fad it's a fat it's a fat
it's a fat it's a fad it's a fad
and for me it was this is going to
completely change the world
i'm completely convinced that everybody
will live
in a fully encompassing nft world in a
decade
and i don't make predictions like this
and end up being wrong i just don't i
understand humans too much
i think this is going to be too big and
i'm excited to be
in this time because i you know i
invested in ethereum in 1617 because i
believed in what they were building for
this moment i just didn't spend my time
until it became more consumer-centric
which i think you have done really well
in your career and i think that's
why we're here right now it's now in the
dawn of consumer centricality right i'm
can you give me my oculus
real quick like matt i don't know if how
it's right over there bro
i don't know how much you're playing
with vr yet or at all
but yeah actually i'm involved in a
company uh three data they're doing uh
vr
data visualization this is what ethereum
was
seven years ago for me six five years
ago for me right
i know this is coming it may not be this
clunky by the time it comes to this
moment in seven years but it's coming
i just won't talk about it a lot but boy
oh boy
when it comes that's all i'm gonna talk
about and i think we are in
the beginning of it matt your thoughts
absolutely i mean this
like like mark was saying earlier i feel
we're in we're at 1995 with the internet
and there was a big flood stage with the
internet like mark was saying
don't enter your credit card a lot of
fear in the media
even that movie the net with sandra
bullock
instilling fear so a lot of people still
have that fear they're they're afraid to
uh
dip their toe in the water so what i
tell people is just
just do it make some nfts get in the
game and and learn
and make mistakes and just you know have
fun with it because
nfts are here to stay and there's
there's there's a huge future
for nfts i mean coming you know
as as a lawyer i can see you know nfts
for ip like copyrights
you know for uh musicians not just to
make money by you know selling songs but
they can
make nfts of copyrights and people can
own
part of their copyrights and it's also a
way for people to invest in the future
of an artist that they believe in like a
musical artist like if if an artist
wants to raise some money need to
produce some tongs they can actually
issue nfts of their copyrights
which people can be a part of their
community but also
actually potentially earn income in the
future from these copies it's my number
one thing that i keep telling
you know what my number one go-to on
that is matt imagine one of the first
200 fans of nirvana
exactly went to the coffee shop or bar
bought one of their nfts owned point one
percent of teen spirit
and now sit every day and watch spotify
send you ungodly levels of money
exactly exactly i can't wait to mention
i'm gonna do that matt i'm going to get
very involved in music for that reason
i've been so right
i'm good you know mike boyd and i spend
a lot of time together
guessing which hip hop artists are going
to pop and we have a great track record
the fact now that in two years i know
that they're going to be doing that i'm
going to be buying up
it's awesome that i was right about
ghana and the baby it would be way more
awesome if i was getting one percent of
all
the royalties on spotify right now right
and and it could be done for movies if
you're an independent filmmaker
and producing a film you can issue nfts
which are going to be collectible as
well but
it's a way for people to invest in the
film and if the film does well
then you can get a nice return from that
and even imagine
like playing fantasy sports for real
like you can you can securitize
part of of someone's income and turn
that into an nft collectible
and pretend like if you have a draft a
rookie we have a rookie draft every year
for our dynasty league so imagine like
do
really having a rookie draft and
thinking you know what players are going
to be big
and and potentially earning income from
that in the future
what's um what's either what
either one you can take either what are
you most convicted about
100 it's gonna happen and what are you
still most hazy about as you're
strategizing in your mind you're like
i don't see what's gonna maybe this
could you know that those two things
well i'm i'm pretty convinced that the
the whole nft copyrights
are going to happen now the only issue
or all the legalities with the sec have
to be worked out as far as you know
securities but i don't really
i don't really see that as a problem i
see that working out and there could be
specific
exchanges for securitized nfts
so uh as far as you know being hazy
i mean there's a lot of things you know
up in the air you know with nfts i mean
mainly
like these you know inflated values uh
that we're seeing
but i mean i think everything is is
gonna uh even out
and like in the internet days that we
had crazy values of companies that
had didn't even have any revenue model
it had a name it was insane
they had they had a name and that was it
so the cream
over time the cream you know google
amazon you know rose to the top and all
these
companies that that which is vaporware
fell to the wayside and i think we'll
see that happening with nfts as well
have you been buying nfts
yeah uh i've you know i've got a few
nfts but
um you know i haven't really been much
of a collector yet
uh are you more focused on the shovels
and picks and you're worried about the
gold later
yeah exactly exactly i'm more like
you know i i did the you know three
stooges nfts i said let me just jump in
the game
yeah make some mistakes and learn from
that who had the ip to that
who owned that uh c3 entertainment
was that a fun process did you learn a
lot uh it was fun i mean i'm a huge
stooge fan so it was just
really fun from that standpoint i could
tell my name is you're copping one of
the haircuts
[Laughter]
just for fun just for we got one minute
and i feel like we've given a lot of
value
why did you fall in love with the sieges
with the stooges oh i was watching them
as a kid growing up and it was
it just hit it it just hit i mean
was it dad or grandfather or uncle or
mom or aunt did somebody love it in the
family
no it's just it would just used to be on
like uh used to be on every weekend
and yeah i just it's i mean that
slapstick stuff
is i mean i also love you know like
buster keaton charlie chaplin you know
all those like physical comments guys
matt thank you so much for sharing oh
thanks so much guys great to meet you
next up we have g-money a cryptocurrency
investor and nft collector
in january of 2021 he purchased crypto
punk
number 8219 for 150
000 a record sale at the time sparking
the parabolic rise in crypto punks
best piece of advice that g-money
received was to find
something he'd do for free and then find
somebody to pay him to do it
so he wouldn't feel like it's work
welcome g-money
hey how are you g-money how are you
good excited to be here same um
let's go right to the thing that i'm
sure a lot of people are thinking about
what is it in the early crypto culture
that led to a lot of people doing what
you're doing now which is stay behind
the scenes
use use some of their art or characters
to be their their face keep their
you know enemy like what what what what
do you attest that to
uh well i think a lot of it right is the
self-custody of wallets right
so it's like you know if if uh for
instance like i have my money in a bank
like it's really hard for somebody to
access it because of kyc and aml laws
but if i'm walking down the street and i
self custody my own assets like
you know opsec is more more of an issue
right which is why
you generally find people in crypto uh
more
uh they're they care about their privacy
way more
do you feel like in this last year
you're noticing that change a little bit
and people are
coming out in a different way and and
you you can
feel that consumer shift in the
ecosystem
where people are less concerned about
privacy yeah
um i think people are um
yes and no like i i mean i think you
just have the range right it's a it's a
gray right like some people um you know
i've spoken to people that are anonymous
that
you know will disguise their voices
right like it's you know everybody has
like their range of what they feel
comfortable with
but i think as you gain more adoption of
crypto and nfts like
you're you're most people will be public
for the most part
and you feel as people get more educated
and as technology keeps making
you know non-custodials quote-unquote
safer or
advancements that maybe we can't even
think of right now that will make it
different
you think that will evolve over time
yeah for sure right like the tech will
get there like i always use the example
of
like you know i i'm in my late 30s right
like i started playing video games and
like super mario brothers was my first
game right but that
that's not the final iteration of tech
people just keep innovating
correct your money what uh what do you
think everybody here
aspiring investors done well in this
space as an nft
collector trader what what's a give me
give
me
the g-money bullet points give me the
three-minute riff of things that
everybody here should consider
things you've learned with regards to
investing in the space yes
yeah so uh basically you know like just
buy stuff you like
you know be uh to your point that you
just brought up right like
if you really like a creator or some
sort of creative
and you're buying their early works
you're you know and i do this all the
time myself where it's like
if i find somebody new and i want to
support them right like
that's the best way to do it is just to
support them by their
either by literally what they're making
so that they keep on doing it right and
like you know it
and to your credit like you know you've
been talking about this for years where
it's like
at some point you'll find your audience
right and you just have to keep on
creating and you know your fans will
find you and that's kind of the beauty
of the internet right it's like
you're no longer uh have to be in just
one physical location
in order for people to uh to find you
right like you're just
out there on the internet and everybody
will find you
what what's been most surprising to you
this year
how fast and quickly it grew you know
like i bought
this punk you know my ape in january the
first week of january
and i joked that like i wanted it to be
the first punk to be sold at christie's
or sotheby's
and think i thought it was like five
years out you know let alone
you know five months away uh that we saw
punk sales
uh going going up the chrissies which i
thought was was incredible
what did you see that make you just to
educate everybody what do you pay for
this and what do you what what's your
assessment on
what you think the fair market value is
of this punk
so and then remind everybody how few
apes there are
in the scheme of the ten thousand crypto
punks okay so yeah so there's ten
thousand crypto punks
of those punks there are nine aliens 25
apes
and uh 88 zombies and so of those that
means they're
they're rare within that 10 000 set so
uh you know my first purchase was a
zombie in december
uh and then i was i was stalking the
apes
uh in general for like a month and you
know like the the thing that stuck out
to me was
on the first day of quarantine last year
i bought a playstation
because i figured that was the only way
i was going to survive and uh
you know i download fortnite i wanted to
hear like everything that was going on
and i start playing with my friends and
their nephews and these kids are like 10
11 12 years old
and they're like hey what skins did you
buy i'm like skins do they give me
special powers
and they're like no so i'm like no i'm
not gonna buy any skins fast forward you
know a couple weeks i'm buying all the
skins i can
and this is before i knew what an nft
was and i was like you know there's
going to be a massive super cycle of
digital asset ownership
um and i just was like i don't know how
to capitalize on it yet right because
we're still in like
and like once like i i discovered what
an nft was
and and that was like in the late summer
early fall
and i'm hanging out in discord on
twitter in telegram
and i'm realizing wow like my profile
skin right it's like you know we're
quote unquote in the metaverse right now
you know because we're in these
communities right because it's like what
is a metaverse right like we all think
that it's going to be this vr you know
really submerged
submersive thing and it's coming for
sure but like we're living in the
metaverse now
i mean that was that was what i thought
about social media
yeah i thought that was the metaverse
and i feel like you couldn't have been
more right to me what was happening
in fortnite nba 2k madden by the way you
know what it really hit me
was farmville yeah like there's a video
there's a video of me in 2011 talking
about virtual goods
and i was like because that was when i
was really studying facebook
behavior i was like people are buying
virtual [ __ ] sheep
yeah i mean it's crazy right like and
you know when i realized that and it's
it's almost like the consumerism of the
western world right where it's like
people are conditioned to be like
oh i'm going to buy this because this
you know whatever this product is what
does it convey about me as a person
right
and it's like on in the digital realm
you're still going to see the same
things but it's just like
you get a little more um uniqueness to
it right because
it's also it's also a tradable
interchangeable asset
yeah which is like think about that
everybody when i bought
when when some parent if you're watching
right now when you bought all those
power rangers for your kid 20 years ago
you eventually sold those five years
later when your kid got out of power
rangers
in a garage sale for 20 bucks to someone
like me
who then sold them for 200 bucks on ebay
with with where we're going with nfts
when your kid gets out of those nfts
you're going to trade them on the open
marketplace potentially
for a profit
yeah it's incredible right like the the
upside
uh like the implications of it are
insane and like once i like wrapped my
head around that
i was like wow like this is there's no
doubt in my mind that this is the future
are you excited about the smart contract
and the things that can be attached to
the digital asset have you been thinking
about that obviously i cared about that
with b
friends have you been looking at that is
that in part of your strategy as you
think about what is interesting to you
yeah i mean the like the thing that i
love about nlts is that
everything in the real world is an nft
right so like
that to me when i realized that i'm like
this is not a fad this is here to stay
so using that framework right it's like
you can be as creative as you want you
know like to your credit like what i
loved about your launch was like
the inclusion of you know these these
real live events that
people throw there's a ton of value on
that right and right you know like it's
not just like hey i'm going to come in
here and ma
and and and gee for me it was let me do
something super valuable in the up front
so that everyone's patient because the
way i'm going to build out these
characters
i want my original ogs to really win but
i don't want them to
have to wait because there's so much
flexibility and and
i mean we just saw it right yesterday
was a wild day like
you know i want it and so that's how i
thought about that
and there's a million other ways people
are going to think about things because
of that
yeah no i totally agree and and that's
the thing is when people come to me with
like new ideas
they're like oh hey like you know what
do you think of this and like how do you
suggest i do this i'm like you could be
as creative as you want
and then you just have to figure out how
to work that into a smart contract right
and that's like the beauty of of where
we are uh at this point in like the tech
cycle
uh you might not have one but in the
last minute i'm gonna ask you for it any
project that you think is
emerging that's very low price that
might be a good entry point for some of
the
obviously punks are at a price range for
many anything capture your eye that's
just launched that might still be
uh affordable for many right now
there's nothing that i'm really eyeing i
mean you know i i'm
personally like with regards to punks
like i'm a huge punk maxie as as you
know as we've discussed in the past but
like
me too if you can get a fractionalized
version of a punk that's
that's a good way to get punk exposure
without having to
you know drop a large sum on it jimani
thank you so much
all right thank you cheers next we
welcome
peoplepleaser a digital artist known for
her collaborations with various d5
protocols
recently her work on the uniswap v3
animation raised over 600 grand for
charity
by selling it as an nft and subsequently
inspired the formation of pleaser dao
her life motto is loosen up homie and
she lives by
the best advice she got have good ideas
be skillful and treat people nicely
well people pleaser hey thanks for
having me
how are you not bad it's a nice day in
the city today
that it is which makes me happy so why
don't you give everybody a little one
minute on you and
kind of your journey two three minutes
on your nft journey
yeah definitely i started selling nfts
probably like last summer
um but nothing very serious um and
my claim to fame sort of was so i was
all this time like collaborating with a
bunch of d5 protocols which are
decentralized protocols if anybody
doesn't
know what that is it's pretty big and
crypto and i was
just making sort of animations for them
because that's what i have been doing as
my job for a long time i was working at
like blizzard before on their cinematics
and stuff
and yeah i just thought that with my
skill set i could bring some fun to the
crypto space
and then sort of my claim to fame within
the nft space was
uh back in march i had made um
this animation for unisof b3 and then
sold it as an nft and then it sold for
310 ethereum
which the whole amount was pledged to
amtec supporting anti-asian hate
charities and non-profit organizations
and
here we are today but uh what was cool
about this case was that
um a specific dow was formed to buy the
nft
uh there was a bidding war at the end
why don't why don't you educate
everybody on
this uh incredible new organizations
called daos
yeah so decentralized autonomous
organizations
aka daos are essentially
basically these groups of people who
have the same sort of
like goal and you can use blockchain
technology to pull money together and
make decisions together on
the blockchain so for everybody you know
just
a group of people they all pull together
they have their rules and then they buy
together
and it's been a really cool and
interesting phenomenon for sure in this
space
what um what was your expectations for
how much
your 310 eth project would have went for
no [ __ ]
don't go humble but don't go making
something like genuinely genuinely what
was your gut
i always go by ranges and um so i have
like a worst case scenario best case
scenario and in my head worst case
scenario was
single digit ease and best case scenario
was over
six figures in terms of us dollar value
so you were just thrilled yeah
basically if it was like 100k i would
have been over the moon
so obviously i did not expect that did
you
did did the success of that lead to
a ton of new opportunities for you uh
yeah i mean
i had always been sort of very engaged
within the d5 crypto community
anyway so i think it definitely opened
up a lot of doors in terms of
um publicity or maybe more on the nft
side of things
but i'm never gonna abandon my
d5 the community of course it's your
community i resonate with and i
love but yeah of course i'm grateful for
all the doors and
i'm excited to see where the dao is
headed actually so
what um what are you most
curious about from a consumer or human
behavior thing so obviously the doubts
you just mentioned right
uh d-a-d-a-o everybody
uh who's in the chat there we go
sebastian thank you um
what else has really intrigued you in
the last month or two or three like
oh that's wild or or something like i
still don't have it figured out in my
brilliant head
how this is going to play out to be
completely honest with you
when the whole pleaser dao thing formed
i actually didn't understand the scope
of it myself
um but so then i looked into it a little
bit later and why
people thought it was a really big deal
and uh essentially i mean i think
first metallic was saying about uh
something about how
nfts can further instantiate its own
legitimacy as an asset
by committing to donate some of the
revenue uh to social institutions that
align with people's values and that's
sort of
um very in line with what caesar dao is
doing and also that
we're living in sort of like an age
where decentralized internet communities
um that figure out how to organize
themselves
um are really important and the but the
reason why these are now is so
intriguing as well is because they're
one of the most
organized um entities that are just like
they see i mean
they've gone on to purchase the snowden
nft for 224 ethereum and then recently
the tour project
nft that was also two million dollars um
and
they are very very organized it's
basically like
uh the dream of silicon valley or
something they can like pull funds
really quickly and
act quickly and expand quickly as well
um and
i think dows actually sit a level above
nfts um so they can
not only own nfts but perhaps maybe even
like create nfts and do a lot of other
things too
um it's really transformative i think
and uh so you can think of an
nft as a piece of digital media but a
dow could actually be an entire company
in that sense right totally 100
what are your normal friends think about
all this [ __ ]
um most of my normal friends don't know
about my crypto identity or even is that
true
yeah so your normal friends or at least
the outside of your most core friend
group actually have no clue
yeah i don't think they have any clue do
you love that
i i kind of like to keep it a little bit
separate yeah what about when one of
them
finds out like as which i assume has
happened at this point has that been fun
um yeah sometimes and definitely you
know i'm always grateful
i think it's mostly that i find it uh
beneficial to
educate people about like cryptocurrency
or the blockchain
i mean in the past i didn't talk to
people about it because i just assumed
that they weren't interested but now
with
nfts blowing up i'm seeing more and more
of my real-life friends
actually just genuinely gaining interest
in this and so they would reach out to
me and be like
can you tell me what an nft is what is
this about and
that part is exciting so if they
genuinely want to learn about themselves
then i'm always happy to talk to them
why don't you while we got you for three
minutes why don't you break down deep
eye
in your most 101 layman's terms because
we're not going to touch on that too
much here
but obviously i'm aware of your strength
and and
being part of that community i think
could be valuable for somebody to go
down a rabbit hole
yeah so um defy also known as
decentralized
finance is basically a sort of
entire new community and form of finance
that has been made possible through
cryptocurrency and blockchain technology
and
most of the protocols are either using
um
just uh technologies that are available
that uh through
either like yield farming or you can
take out loans um there's all these
things that you can do which are
concepts that we're already familiar in
traditional finance um
but i would say uh to sort of explain it
like i'm five it's like
uh it's now being done quicker and like
way more automate automated because of
the technology and because of
yeah the software that's like available
or sorry with the code and
um everything that makes it possible and
so it's kind of like traditional
finance but on steroids so there's a lot
of really lucrative yields
um and apys that for example you know
traditional banks really pale
in this comparison because they're
offering like
point zero two percent apis on your
uh the money that you put in a bank or
something but in d5 anything
you know around like the eight to ten
percent is very commonly seen and
yeah it's just a way for people you know
even if i think a lot of nft artists can
benefit from learning about this as well
without getting into make money
make money on your money and even if
you're lazy you know and you don't want
to do like
a bunch of farming or like really get
into it you can park your
stable coins or ethereum or even bitcoin
whatever you want like
on specific uh d5 protocols and just
just earn
interest off of that you know as opposed
to having it do nothing
so highly encourage artists to look into
it especially if they're earning each
now on their nfts
what's what do you think is next for you
in this last minute what
any give me a sneak preview of something
you're potentially plotting
potentially plotting um i mean i i love
making videos
so i just love the storytelling aspect
of it so i would
love to experiment with maybe longer
form videos
maybe even i don't know short films
movies who knows um
but yeah i mean we might even see a
future where nfts could be an animated
movie or something
um you never know and i also am excited
about the universe i mean sorry in the
metaverse
and uh also excited about what cesar dao
is up to
um you know what i really like the ethos
that they're going for
and everything that's happening and by
the way
they're throwing a party in brooklyn
this saturday
so if anybody who's watching this is
interested in coming to hang out
um have you have you shared it on your
social on this account
uh yeah uh you can find me you know on
twitter or on
instagram uh and yeah i'll probably be
sharing details when we know more but
it's gonna be in brooklyn on saturday
come hang you that's awesome thank you
for the invite thanks for being on the
show
yeah thanks we'll see you there
next we welcome jim mcnellis a
cryptocurrency minor and founder
and ceo of nft 42 a platform that builds
applications leveraging blockchain
technology
with a specific focus on nfts
jimmy's inspiration is michael jordan's
story as he tells it
i've missed more than 9 000 shots in my
career lost almost 300 games
and missed 26 of game winning shots i
failed over and over again in my life
and that's why i
succeed welcome jimmy thank you adrian
jimmy i love you so much as being my
true partner in crime and be
friends but the fact that michael jordan
i mean we've started this interview off
in a very difficult manner
[Laughter]
jimmy uh so everybody's watching if you
go to vfriends.com right now which i
would love if you scroll all the way
down to
the site on the bottom right hand side
you'll see that it is powered by a
platform called nameless
which is an incredible platform that
jimmy diaz
crew at nft 42 have built out and are
building out and
you know i bet my wagon and hitched my
wagon to it and think anybody who's got
an ambitious
nft project should consider from the
biggest brands in the world
gee what uh what why don't you tell the
story of
v friends from your perspective and
intertwine
your ogenes your block chain gang
your your your ethos you know i think
there's a
fun five-minute story of the friends
that can be told where you can
intertwine
both what was interesting i'm i'm je we
haven't even been able to fully recap
yet so i'm almost being selfish here
you know what was interesting about that
things you didn't you didn't expect
or or other things that will bring value
so what's the story and then more
importantly
from your perspective not mine and and
the things that
were challenges and exciting things and
things people should keep an eye out for
yeah uh so i i thought i think it's a
really
cool story and a really exciting one for
me personally um so thanks for having me
on today giving an opportunity to share
um
so you know a few months ago i guess
uh you showed up in some discord
channels like crypto punks and
the like and then i remember you joined
a smaller group um with a few of us
and we're hanging out and then uh one
day i had a dm from you like hey jimmy
it's garyvee
um and then i think you got my number
and i got a text from you a few days
later like let's talk
so we got on the phone and we talked
about nfts and you i was really
impressed right off the bat like you had
done your homework you know you already
owned a bunch of bugs at that point i
don't think i knew that but like you've
done your homework and uh
you know we talked about what uh what we
had just done we had raised around and
we're building out this uh
platform we didn't have a name at the
time actually the fact that it turned
out to be nameless there's a bit of
irony in that because we changed names
every week for uh
over a month um but then uh
we we spoke and you wanted you cared a
lot about making sure that your project
was viewed as a legitimate project and
that you weren't taking any of the
shortcuts that would net
in the tokens being uh deemed as not
uh legitimate in any way or that they
could be interrupted you wanted
everything to be on chain which
is like kind of like my mantra and i
reach it so you know you and i connected
on that immediately and for me it was
amazing because
i think i shared with you at the time
when i started my last business in 2007
and growing through that web two phase
seeing you
as somebody who was teaching people how
to go out and build uh their brand and
build their businesses around these new
technologies and everything else and
i've
seen you come into nfps i was like oh
wow here he goes again
it was web 2 and now he can hear he's
going with web3 and now i get the
opportunity to actually work with you to
do this like
what an amazing journey and so it was
off to the races pretty quickly
right you know you knew what you wanted
to do you knew you had a lot of work to
do we told you what we could help
help with and what you needed to do and
you went out and did it
and we worked really hard to keep up
with you and to follow in your wake for
the next uh
i don't know about seven or eight weeks
i think and uh
yeah so you know i think uh we both
learned
jimmy what surprised you the most
uh today at this exact moment it could
be any part of the cycle
what surprised me the most was how well
you did onboarding
new people into the nft and blockchain
and ethereum world and teaching them how
to use wallets and
how to set up their metamask and what
ethereum is and how to buy it off
coinbase and
what why it matters like you
you when uh the metrics that i've looked
at like over the last week you know
obviously very impressive ten thousand
five hundred each more than that
um we saw that the withdrawal function
worked on the contract today so we're
all really excited about that
um over four
when i checked several days ago it was
over 4 200 people
who had uh gd friends in their wallet
that's 4 200 unique owners out of
just over 10 000 tokens that's a really
high ratio
of new people in the space too but also
tokens
to owner's ratio for a brand new project
it's a very well distributed supply
and look i helped a lot of people on
these launch days
with their wallets individually i had to
teach them how to actually do a custom
nonce in their wallet which is a really
advanced thing
and many of them had zero as their
announce number which is their first
transaction and these people figured it
out you're really smart
uh you have a really smart community
like everybody really
is educated and they take what you say
seriously about educating yourself and
know those 50 hours because i'm
explaining these things and they're
picking up on it really fast
so really really really impressed with
the community and the ability to bring
new people
into this new technology or giving them
an opportunity um now on the ground
floor they're going to own v
friends and expand through that and and
make new connections within those
communities and find their groups within
those communities
and then those people are going to go
and start to explore nfps and understand
them more
about from there i'm excited to see any
derivative projects that come off of
this as well the
the pigeon that you did yesterday with
the apparel line yes i went immediately
and looked i was like oh do i
do i have the right pigeon and i didn't
i know there's two pigeons in the
collection
i hope you're doing that more and i i'm
excited you know i believed in the
project i degen myself i bought about 10
of the
regular access tokens i bought a couple
special ones and i
right now i'm holding the courtside cat
which is you know the three games
uh madison square garden you know three
years in a row i fully expect you to
hodl at least once we can have a nice
time at the game but then i'm planning
on this year we're gonna do it we're
gonna show everybody how awesome it is
and then it's
you and i are both gonna make some money
off of that one buddy and what
what he means by that is he then resells
it i've got a nine percent royalty
because i
i'm donating one percent of all
secondary royalties to charity
jimmy um what about
what have you heard from which have you
have you yet heard from big intellectual
property or other
people with large audiences since and
and
has what i dreamed happened or not
happened which was
my hope and you know this was to create
a blueprint
that other brands and individuals could
look at and say oh wait a minute i'm not
just going to do an image
i got to do more i gotta create more
value for my community
have has that happened yet it's starting
to happen for sure
we you know we haven't done any pr or
press or anything around this at all
on our end it's really just been from
your promotion and people
people who actually are looking at that
nameless name on the website and looking
deeper and finding out
how to find me yes it's happening and as
you know
you know you're an investor of ours as
well you know we're engaged with some
really awesome
brands and exploring some opportunities
in the nft space so
i'm extremely excited about what's
coming i'm actually a little bit scared
um because we're because there's so much
coming and we're still a small team
that's growing very quickly so
we're trying to build a platform and
right now we're having to do these
one-off since we're learning what that
platform is your project
god we learned so much gary and it's
going to make every project we do in the
future so much better
it's just an amazing starting point for
the nameless brand really and i i can't
express enough gratitude
for your faith and our ability to pull
it off and and hanging with us and
and making that that weak delay was a
little rough for everybody but we made
it through
retrospective there's lessons learned
but we made it through and this is
you know for the long term so you know
in the grand scheme of things
what is the temperature of the nft
collector community that you're a big
part of
um so what about yesterday what about
yesterday were people
you know freaked out excited like i
bought a bunch of ethereum yesterday
i was happy even though i was losing a
lot with what i was sitting on from the
project
i was excited and kind of took advantage
of it i you know
when i believe in something i believe in
something yeah i i did a tweet late last
night that said you know
i'm like 99 nft so i wasn't impacted by
the uh the drop right because you're not
sitting on the e
you're sitting on the assets from it and
and those of us
yeah i was talking to everybody in
discord i'm like you know because right
before eath was hot before my project i
was like don't buy beef friends
it's gonna be ten thousand and and i
went in there i'm like what about now
you're still gonna get three years of v
con
same way and it's in half like you know
that's just part of the game
yeah and the interesting thing about
nfts and investing and stuff here is is
that
it can work both ways like right now
crypto punks are like half of what they
were
um they'll eventually like find their
way back up to where they were before or
maybe even higher
um but the price of the asset can then
be adjusted
in ethereum to reflect the dollar value
and you're not actually just stuck
holding a fixed amount of the ethereum
when it drops to
whatever it drops to so there's there's
a it's like 40 investing
strategies and things like that but it
can work out really well and it can work
out the other way
um but i think the temperature is like
people
look everybody's been we we went through
these crypto winners the last couple
years those of you
who are basement ico winter was cold
yeah i mean we spent two years just like
collecting nfps when no one thought this
stuff was going to do anything i mean
gas was like one or two
right it was 260 even when you deployed
your
tokens since i'm losing you in a second
yep sorry any no no i'm sorry any
project
that's really inexpensive that you like
to
you know not like an official investment
advice but i know a lot of people are
trying to get into something
anything anything captured i know this
is a tough spot maybe there is no other
thing which is fine no there is and i
just you know
you haven't bought a bought way too much
i never succeeded in
shelling my own project avastar's is
still the best deal in the in the town
it's point zero seven eight to buy a
common
avastar that's completely honest how
many stars did you make
uh there's gonna be 25 000 total there's
about 4 500 left you go to avistars.io
you buy one it's on chain forever it's
the first u.s dollar
what's the what's the us dollar version
right now uh
i don't know i guess it would be 120
27.50 right now
yeah my guess is like 120 150 bucks
unfortunately i mean sorry about that we
fixed the price to point zero seven
ethereum a year ago
so some people got these for like 15
bucks but uh you could go on the second
market open see if you can find one
cheap you really can't
so you know that's the .07
thank you jimmy all right take care talk
to gary
so gary wanted to close out this episode
and just give you a chance to riff a
little bit about
v friends and nfts but also welcome
some questions from our audience and um
you know just
just kind of round out all the
conversations that we've already had
um team if you could put the discord url
while i'm talking that would be my first
piece of advice i've been blown away by
the friends discord it's also linked to
my instagram right now
um that would be the first thing i would
say andrea
and i've said it as you know i've said
this to the leaders of our company like
the community itself is educating in a
way i'm in there constantly
and the jimmy's in there a ton so
first and foremost education education
education the reason i asked
you know jimmy about an inexpensive one
and he's right his project avastar's is
very underpriced in my opinion as well
and
obviously i love them but um i think
that um
this is a game of education like if
you're picking up on what these two
hours
were putting down it was it's very clear
that a lot of people that have
historical success
of being right about things that haven't
seemed obvious
you know um are sitting here saying hey
you know i always laugh like my one
buddy reached out and said
gave me a whole manifesto of why nfts is
not going to happen
and i asked him where he got this from
his and he said this guy at work
and i said brother you've known me my
whole life you've watched everything
i've talked about
happen in a way that nobody thought
would happen you've got people like mark
cuban
talking about you know your [ __ ]
buddy from work
people are built on fear and so end
on greed fear and greed is what i'm most
worried about right now
fear because people are like this is
just a fad it's [ __ ] and they never
put the 50 hours of homework they don't
jordan six discords they don't learn
and they never get there right yeah we
are reasons to dismiss it right read
because greed makes bad decisions right
somebody somebody in our discord
uh listed their fee friend on on open c
and the person tricked them and offered
them 25 cents
not 25 ethereum and they sold it
so they bought something for 9 000 and
sold it for 25 cents
and the community and discord and my
team and me myself are like damn it and
feel bad
but i i'd be lying if i didn't say
that's a greed move you don't buy
something for three ethereum
and sell for 25 in two seconds yeah or
seven or nine whatever it was
you know greed and
and lack of education will get you into
trouble and so
greed and fear are the two things that
i'm trying to really get people in so
discord.com invite slash be friends
um you know orb to make it much easier
go to my url uh in my instagram right
now
as far as v friends look v con is
amazing going to a basketball game with
me or being part of a facetime or
or a hangout on hangout hawks like
there's a lot of cool stuff but all of
that is
wildly secondary even the three years of
vcon
vcon.com.co
even that is just a short term
i'm looking to build out this
intellectual property and
and really make this digital asset
something that's worth
having and so obviously you know me very
well
um you know i'm very passionate about
good behavior in human beings
and and i also you also know that i'm
self-aware
which means i know not everyone is gonna
put
pick up what garyvee is putting down i'm
too much i'm too aggressive
my conviction and excitement comes
across
to some people luckily a smaller amount
than
the other way but not good or i'm this
or i'm that
because i am competitive and i am alpha
and i know that turns some people off
the the fact that i now have a countable
ant
you know this is real for me that i have
patient panda
that i have offense oriented orangutang
that you know that i have focused falcon
you know that i have humble hedgehog
like the fact that i have this universe
now
i think i'm going into a very
interesting part of my career where i'm
going to be able to
make an impact around kindness and
empathy and all these things
uh and really make a difference through
the
character development and whether it's
cartoons or
stuffed animals or collectible desk toys
or comic books
or you know ice capade shows or a zoo or
who the hell but i'm um i'm gonna pull
this off just like everything else i
said that everybody said i wouldn't
and and i'm excited about having my
early community be part of that journey
so one thing that didn't come up today
was um we didn't hear any rants about
sustainability or any of those kind of
things any perspective there
i think it's because the you know
there's a million things in the world
that are you know this is not
great for the right like i think that
i am so impressed with the overall
community
on even ethereum itself which has one of
the bigger vulnerabilities
because is switching and and the
evolution of proof-of-work to
proof-of-stake like
like it seemed i think the reason and
there's plenty of articles but the
reason it's not
like overwhelming everybody is almost
nobody's saying
go [ __ ] yourself right everyone's saying
you're right let's do something about
this and
blockchains are being built that are
good ethereum's level two is being built
on that so like
i i think that it's because huma most
humans
it my big thing with all issues is why
not
why not make it grief for the
environment if you can as quickly as
possible
why not be nice to your fellow man or
woman like why not
why not why not you can have both you
can be successful you can be
fulfilled and you can be selfless and
leave a legacy and do the right things
i think some people get caught into
extremes some people live in a world of
scarcity and so it's winner takes all
it's all this garbage
other people live in an ideology they're
not practical they want people to do
things tomorrow
that are not real to a lot of people
without a lot of destruction so
it's about compassion empathy and lack
of judgment i think that's
like how i see that gary what's the
conversation
that you have with your parents are they
surprised that you're doing this
and uh you know just would love to hear
a little bit about that
i went down to miami to spend time with
my parents this last weekend off the
heels of the launch
they are as proud as parents can be
um they re you know my parents are my
parents so like by the way
think about how much better you know me
compared to everybody who's watching
this
yeah and what that actual delta is
between
garyvee and who and like the small
little like
i can't even begin to comprehend how big
the gap is i think it's actually quite
extraordinarily large
yes now imagine what my parents gap is
to you
they know everything they've seen me
completely live
every day of my life they know who i am
they know
where my heart sits so for me you know
for my parents it's kind of like
they're just pr and don't forget where
my parents come from they were 22
23 years old came to america had nothing
to their name nothing
right so like for them it's a level of
pride
a level of surreal a level of like
fun validation they also know that their
kid
fought the system you know they know
that their kid
didn't conform to school you know and
they know
everything they know everything so and i
have an incredible relationship my
parents they're only
20 years older than me you know and
you know i'm 20 years older than people
on my team
and in my company right and you're you
know this you're 20 years older than
some of the people in our company and
your team and it kind of feels like
you're friends sure you're maybe a
little bit of a
you don't feel like a parent you feel
like an older you know you know i don't
feel like
because i'm 20 years older and people on
my team like their dad i feel like
they're older wise friend
and in a weird way my parents close
proximity and age with me
allows for a very unique relationship
i've also been
um i've also been
incredibly um unique in my relationship
with my parents
you know we have such a partnership
through the years so
it's uh it's a great thing you guys all
learn from one another and that's the
same thing that we have at vayner we
learn
from everybody right and it's uh it's
it's so beautiful to see what you've
created that's
that's um you know just celebrates
exactly who you are as a human as well
as an entrepreneur
congratulations thank you uh i love
everybody hope everybody has a great day
thanks for this we'll talk to you soon
hope you enjoyed it please hit me up on
twitter with your thoughts on this
episode of marketing
for the now thanks andrea thank you gary
all right and then
our next show uh is going to be on june
17th at 12 p.m we're going to mix things
up a little bit
uh this summer uh so please join us
we're gonna hear from ceos and founders
as well as marketers
check out check us out and check out
past recordings
on mftn.vaynerx.com
we'd love to hear from you and hear what
you liked and how we can continue to
to grab your attention marketing for the
now at vaynerx.com
thanks everybody